thirty-eight years ago and the fact that
Star Wars was such a great success then
that gave me the opportunity to be busy
it was a ball it was really fun JJ was a
great party host and it was like a Star
Wars party we have the potential for
this being appropriate and look forward
to and in every country in the world
happily transcends borders well happily
that's been the kind of family film that
that gets passed on from mothers and
fathers to their kids and that's been
great for Star Wars it's also been great
for me really grateful thank you it's
weird because it's I'm both nervous for
this whole thing and then I'm like oh my
god it's um it's exciting but it's scary
yeah definitely scary we have been in
Seoul and Tokyo and that was amazing
because I went to Tokyo in April so to
be back was amazing the reception was so
good
Seoul was great we had this amazing kpop
band there so it was over it was all
very exciting
it's amazing cuz Blue Peter and Oscar
got to go to Mexico nopsi we were in
Asia we've been in the US and the UK
Germany and it's just so far-reaching
it's really like astounding and special
because we haven't all been in the same
room together for a long time so it's
nice it's nicely we're all gonna be
together so excited to see what's going
down tonight I mean I'm having such an
amazing time I can't fathom this
experience it's fantastic I feel so good
right now so good
when South Korea Tokyo we were doing
press in the UK here in LA New York and
so it's been really really fun yeah I
mean through the years you know there's
so many Star Wars fans that are so
committed to this story and the
characters and to be a part of something
that continues this legacy it's just
amazing I feel so good and I feel so
blessed oh oh yeah I mean it's it's very
fun and it's quite the experience to be
in this position and to be at a point
where I'm interacting with the old
characters and the new is fantastic well
this is the first time we've been on
Hollywood Boulevard for a premiere
because we didn't have a premiere when
it first opened they just opened it up
so it's a long time coming and since it
was so unexpected in my life I've been
having more fun with it I guys I have I
think a better appreciation now than I
did at the time so I'm really enjoying
it because this really isn't about
recapturing what we did before it's
about you know making that jump to
hyperspace into the future and the new
generation of villains and heroes that
was probably the most unexpected thing
is that it never really went away and it
gave me a passport to use all over the
world where I'm everybody's friend it's
installing so to see people that were
children at the time grown with their
own children now sometimes even
grandchildren it's a generational thing
and it's appropriate because these
stories are fables and fairy tales that
have always been handed down generation
to generation so it seems appropriate
it's just wonderful
it really is it's it's been such a long
time coming this day I think that it
felt I could have become the stuff of
legend and it's really wonderful to be
here and celebrate this wonderful film
I I truly feel so privileged to be a
part of I think Star Wars has touched
people I think it's done something that
uh is really unique which is in watching
in watching the films it really gives
people the feeling of hope and I think
what's wonderful is that Lucasfilm and
Disney have captured that feeling again
but they brought it right up to date
with more diverse casting choices and by
creating a character like Captain phasma
that I'm so privileged to play it was a
very moving experience watching the film
and I think it's a really great piece of
work well yes I mean this is a very new
experience to me because obviously I've
been lucky enough to be on Game of
Thrones for a long time but this is this
is one of my first films so I'll be
sharing this new experience with
everyone else I mean it is palpable that
I feel like the whole world's been
waiting for this moment and now we've
all converged here and there's about to
be an awakening well I went to Mexico
and it was a homecoming of sorts and it
was just you could feel the excitement
in the air there was a roof Oriya almost
and at this point even before the film
comes out people knows a lot of facts
about Stowers 7 I mean it it was really
so much fun to see so many people loving
a film that is yet to come
I think this is the one film that is I
feel is meant to be seen and with a
crowd and I think tonight is gonna be
particularly special because I feel like
the die-hard fans are going to be in the
room and we get to give them this gift
that is Star Wars 7 it is extraordinary
I mean you know I don't think anybody
expected that it would that it would you
know reemerge really well that's nice we
kind of did but but for it to emerge and
then to be asked to be part of it was
pretty extraordinary and it was such a
great honor and such a great pleasure to
meet JJ and and him asked me the
question and the way phrased it as well
are emblazoned on my memory really he
said today he said at the Andy Andy sir
it's the only way that you would like to
that you could see yourself engaging in
the Star Wars universe just like I can
see myself engaging their star quite
easily actually yeah so so here we are
and it's been an amazing journey and
he's such a brilliant director a
fantastic fantastic leader and such
passion love for the material and and
just couldn't be a better guy to be
helming it really I mean it was it's
really his passion and spirit and I mean
everything that you use as an artist is
up there on the screen he's amazing
there's nothing like going to share
experience you know there's nothing like
there's nothing like getting you know a
large group of people to go through the
same emotions together and and feed off
that and and to experience that and to
laugh and cry and and be terrified and
be you know you know feel the Jeopardy
together it's just this there really
isn't anything like that and and and
these films take you absolutely on that
journey and give you all of that I mean
that's the strength of these movies I
think is the the characters and that
they it isn't
soli the united states there's so many
no universal themes in the movie that
seems so obvious but i think it's rare
that one movie kind of encapsulates so
many of that and in Korean at the same
time paying such a realistic world that
people have made their own you know and
so it feels very personal in in a really
great way I'm pretty pretty lucky to be
a part of it I've never done it before
this is my first time seeing something
I've been in with this this kind of this
group of well not this group of people
we just put with an audience so we'll
see how it goes but for me so far has
been the most exciting just one so I can
talk about it I guess a little bit to
the people that are close to me but also
just sharing something that felt so
collaborative I'm working on it finally
sharing it with people is I think the
biggest payoff
Star Wars when it came it was something
new that that inspired so many people
young particularly young people and it
has been very important I think morally
through the years not just c-3po but the
whole galaxy of the family of Star Wars
and now we've got three generations who
just love it and and I'm delighted that
Threepio is still there and so am I so
you know I'm just very lucky and the
story of Star Wars is so enduring and
gorgeous and whatever and people will go
on sharing it for another generation at
least I travel a lot and just matter
whether it's Australia or Japan or India
or Russia the other day it's a common
language that everybody shares and you
know with John Williams music
particularly supporting it everybody
knows about Star Wars and it's not just
the films it's the whole spin-off
activity the the five-o first the
cosplay players people who've gone into
all sorts of sciences and in industry
because of Star Wars
I just I'm amazed to be a you know a
tiny little a little gold part of it
who knew it's wonderful to be back be in
here where it was born where premieres
were and it's just a fabulous feeling
Chewie is a teddy bear and everybody has
had to tell you about I don't care
whether it's you or the cameraman you've
all had teddy bears at some stage so
that it's what appeals to the whole
group of families whether it's there or
you know that they can be 80 and they
could be eight and it still appeals to
them it's insane I mean it's it's it's a
crazy crazy evening but I'm I'm just
excited to see the film you know I think
that's why we're all here is to see the
film so all this stuff is madness
in-between but then the lights to go
down it'll get very exciting I grew up
in Ireland you know it's a long way away
it's you know it's not a quick plane
ride and and even there you know
obviously even there growing up it was
just all you ever heard about my
cousin's had all the toys which I would
then get passed down to me and it was
it's a phenomenon basically and so it's
very very exciting to be a part of it
it's amazing it's a it's a it's hard to
process what this whole thing is there's
like a mile of press to do but there's
also a mile of friends and beautiful
wonderful people that have been involved
with this movie well yeah yeah it's you
know it talks about family spirituality
you know finding your place in the world
and those are things that everyone no
matter what culture you're born into can
relate to and Latin America star wars is
a rite of passage so it's a for Lupita
and I to bring that to them was amazing
and Kathy Kennedy was amazing it's
exciting for me also even though I've
been with it for so long you know from
the very earliest days with George Lucas
but I think the buzz has never stopped
for us
and for some reason weather particularly
this one I think it seems to have
gathered a new life and a new energy in
the writing
JJ's work it which feels to me like a
very kind of organic extension of what
George Lucas has done initially I'm
excited and very interested to see what
the audience will do tonight I hope they
will love it it's incredible to be here
on a night where we can actually just
have fun it's been so much work and to
get to be here with you know all these
people who were responsible for the
movie all in one place and to get to
share it with you know some fans and
some friends and some family nothing
better what's been so exciting is going
to places like Korea and Japan and
getting reports back from Brazil and and
from Mexico and Australia and you just
see that there's a kind of understanding
of this thing that George Lucas created
has a power that sort of reaches out and
touches you beyond anything that I could
really describe and certainly about any
any other movie that I'm aware of so to
be a part of that at all is incredible
honor I'm most excited everyone to see
Daisy Ridley and John boyega Adam driver
Oscar Isaac domhnall gleeson Lupita
Nyong'o these amazing young actors who
have I think delivered incredible
performances and to do it with
characters that are known and loved and
really beloved it's an incredibly
exciting thing and it's exciting even
for me still and I'm so horribly close
to it so I can't wait people to discover
it for the first time one of the fun
things about you know this movie is a
brand new story about about new
characters you haven't seen before to
have them exist in such an entertaining
way with some of the characters that
already exist in the Star Wars you know
legacy is really a thrilling thing
because it's this weird combination of
stuff that's brand-new and totally you
know created from scratch and then stuff
that is
you know something we love desperately
in our hearts and to work with Lawrence
Kasdan who wrote Empire Strikes Back and
Return of the Jedi was a thrill the
biggest thing ever and looking around
here there's John and everybody I keep
running I just ran into George Lucas
it's the most incredible night and I'm
so excited to have people see it we've
been living with it ourselves for so
long and it's full of fun I think and
and I'm anxious to share that with
people it's kind of amazing because the
people who saw the first one were and
when they were 40 or 80 and my grand my
oldest grandson is five and he's gonna
be seeing it soon that's a big range of
people to be interested in one story you
know and so there's never been a movie I
think where we have potentially that
kind of audience the people who care
about it you know that much that big and
that is I have to say it's so hard to
believe that we're finally at this point
where we're standing on Hollywood
Boulevard
with tents going down for blocks I
understand so it's pretty amazing I
can't wait to get into the theater and
just have people see the movie it is
it's pretty amazing to think that George
created this almost 40 years ago maybe
even a little bit longer and people have
just stayed with it it means something
to them people are looking forward to
seeing the movie with their families
experiencing it with friends I mean
there just aren't a lot of things in our
culture these days that really allows
for that so it's really nice so it's
been fantastic I think Harrison and Cary
and Mark have been unbelievable to our
new cast with Daisy and Finn and John
boyega that who you know are really
really supportive and
then come really wonderful mentors for
them